doing the pitching for the dodgers
walker bueller making his 18th start he
is eight
and one and seven and one over his last
ten starts alone
he's responding to some bad news and
good news bad news is the
last start wasn't his best it's the
first time he didn't go six innings only
went five and gave up a few runs so he's
looking to get back on track there the
good news is
this is his first start since being
named to his second
all-star team so i'm sure he's a little
pumped up and maybe we'll see that here
in the first
inning with the velocities up a tick
just hope he can command the baseball
because he has
dominated these diamondbacks to rojas
swing on this strike three got him rojas
thinks he fouled it off and it hit the
ground and that's what tory laville is
going to argue and home plate umpire
tony randazzo wants to talk to the crew
chief jim reynolds about this
and they have invited rojas back to the
plate and
continue the count at owen 2. rojas went
1-4 last night with a walk and
now he gets it well sooner or later and
it was later
and tori lavello say hey same thing it
hit the ground but
he didn't fall tip it driving backs
manager he's fighting for every pitch
here
dave roberts might be getting a little
impatient early in the ball game
that's that one out over the plate and
pavon drilled it into the right field
corner
lookie bets has it out there and paving
smith
who had a double in the sixth inning
last night as a first hitting double
tonight
2-2 strikeout number two for bueller
both with the breaking ball the
curveball he hasn't busted out the
slider tonight he's shown the cutter
here's the o2 swung on and missed
straight three that will end the inning
mueller strikes out the side gives up a
hit and a walk
diamondbacks come up empty 26
appearances on the year and eight starts
he was very good against the dodgers
earlier this year chase field
shut him out over six innings on one hit
he did walk four batters in that ball
game and coming off a very deceiving
outing against the giants
what six innings in that game gave up
five hits and five runs however three of
those hits came in the very first inning
another all-star chris taylor taylor had
a nine-game hitting streak in last night
taylor hits it on the ground to the left
field up base hit
two on and nobody out taylor is hit
safely now
in 10 of his last 11. the dodgers have
set up shop first and second nobody out
and
now at the plate a guy who's been really
hot and just added to the
all-star club again in the air to right
shallow calhoun coming in and that
retires turner one away
with one out now he'll face a
left-handed hitter and max muncie
bets off of second base taylor off of
first and max
ropes it down the right field line
that's gonna bounce
and stay fair here comes mookie to score
rumbling in behind him as taylor
two muffin dodgers muncie 49 rbis on the
year
and for chris taylor his 62nd run
scored of the season he ranks fourth in
the national league in that category
cody ballinger looking to get that swing
going again
ballinger hammers one deep right failed
way back in his car along the way to
belly bomb
two more runs come in and the dodgers
lead it
four nothing two games before the
all-star break
and summit bats are bigger than others
and this one was
huge for belly to have the days off at
the all-star
game and around it and to go into it
feeling good
it will be big for him aj
has been dialing up the long ball a
little bit this month
2-2 to paula got a fly ball to left that
one is on its
way and the dodgers go back to back in
the bottom of the first it is
five to nothing pollock attacking his
old team giving the dodgers five here in
the first
back to back blasts
all over the diamondbacks in the first
inning friday night fireworks
those were in the sky saturday night
fireworks there at the plate
and there's turner with the bases loaded
[Applause]
how do you like that justin turner with
one swing at the back scores four
nine nothing dodgers what a day what a
goosebump day
get added to the all-star game roster
gonna be headed to colorado what a
beautiful picture and what a great day
for the dodgers and justin turner
there's a fine line between
living the dream and a nightmare tonight
caleb smith a nightmare parade of
all-stars for the dodgers
here's another one max muncie that
two-run double in the first one for two
so far
gets one into right center and caught by
payment smith gets up gets it back in
turner has to go back to first base two
outs i don't know pavemen knew what he
was doing on that looked like the ball
might have been knuckling at him or
something but
he ended up diving straight ahead to
catch that ball
to the right side in a base hit
has done that so often since putting on
the dodger uniform
he has said okay i'll just take the hit
that way
and bellinger swings it's one to left
backing up on it there's peralta he's
there he's got it
he'll retire the side the dodgers get a
couple of hits off
matt peacock and they will leave a pair
about ready to throw his 95th pitch
in search of his eighth strikeout of the
game the one
two grounded up the first baseline
fielded by pujols overhanded flip
to bueller covering and bueller makes
easy work
of the diamondbacks we'll go to the
bottom of the six dodgers nine to
nothing
it's in cruise control for the daunters
tonight they lead
nine to nothing two balls two strikes
two outs bickford to holiday
here's the pitch grounded to third
backhanded stabbed by mckinstry throws
low
dug out by pujol toe what a play at
either corner
the game is nine to nothing dodgers
don't bother telling mckinstry or
foolholtz or bickford for that matter
seventh inning stretch mookie has four
career grand slams
it's hit to left and now he's got
five the dodgers have nine grand
slams and it is 13 to nothing
and mckinsey with a fly ball to left
center field
well hit and it is gone
this is just a good old-fashioned
whoop-it here is albert pujols with the
bases clear and two down
[Applause]
hits the big fly and that's career home
run number 674
and there's a fly ball to left field
pollock has hit his second home run of
the night
17-1 if there was a white
towel to be tossed by the diamondbacks
it would have been tossed a long time
ago
and luck's ground ball base hit rolling
up the line
all the way into the corner barnes has
scored
baby has scored and here comes
[ __ ] the dodgers lead it 20
to 1. and albert
just pulverizes one
two home runs for albert
oh my goodness the 1-2 pitch from reed
and this one's put to bed
22 runs on the board for the dodgers